and I just stood there in three feet of
sewage water as my was like
floating by me getting ruined and I just
stared into the eye of my boyfriend's
ex-girlfriends butthole welcome to this
has not happened
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. nice teeth
let's have a good time
ladies microphone is all about room
the class is called guys we thought
Christie returned
so uh three years ago my commie partner
Kern Fisher nine we started guys we
the anti slut-shaming pod cracks
thank you so much and we started out we
started an interview a guy that one of
us is and in an attempt to kind
of learn more about ourselves and you
know help maybe shed the shame that some
people carry on their shoulders about
their own sexuality and and we kind of
each went into the podcast having a
person in our lives that caused us a lot
of emotional turmoil for Corinne I was
her ex boyfriend who dumped her out of
the blue and left her heartbroken for me
it was a famous porn star named Stoia
who dated my boyfriend for two years
right before I started dating them
comedy gold but she's not what you think
of when he's people like think of a
typical porn star
this girl is stunning she has a face of
Megan Fox and the body of Megan Fox and
then every once in a while she'll
publish this big piece about sexuality
or feminism they'll make you go wow
that's brilliant and you know and when I
first met Stephen they were dating it
was on the set of a music video that he
was directing and I remember we were on
set one day yeah my girlfriend's a
famous porn star named soya and I was
like oh tell me everything and I just
egg him on and tell me all these stories
about their sex life and it was
fascinating and a year later she dumps
him leaves him heartbroken seven days
after that I start dating them and I
gotta say if anybody in here ever has
the opportunity to see their significant
others very attractive very good at sex
ex-girlfriend do a hardcore anal scene
with a coke and dick online don't take
advantage of that situation
it's been putting a weird place for a
couple years turns out yeah they're
gonna do a podcast reading for you every
guy you've ever slept with because you
feel from a skew lated that's why cuz
when that happens yeah that's not a real
word there's no word in the English
language that is the female equivalent
of emasculated which is insane
to me because that is the only way I
could begin describe how it feels to
immediately follow a girl who as part of
her job she'll just walk on stage stage
exactly like this forever purpose
strangers right she'll just take off all
her clothes and come everywhere and then
everyone's like who's the best day in my
life I'll never forget this but then for
my job I walk onstage in front of a
group of strangers fully clothed the
whole time and I'm just like hey Sam I
want to hear a riddle
teacher oh you're gonna jerk off to that
girl's vagina okay I'll keep my rule
right here come to me when her done get
it come I don't know whatever it was
hard it was hard cuz he was still
telling me all these things that I don't
want to hear like one of the worst
things he told me when we started dating
was he said sometimes Steuer she would
take my hand and put it up her skirt to
let me know how wet I made her in public
I was like oh god do I gotta do that I
can do that and I started notice things
like I started to notice that every porn
store in New York City they all the same
poster hanging on the front of their
door and it's just all these chicks like
hot chicks with like pirate outfits on
one of them in an eyepatch but she
somehow like made it hot it was very
confusing and then one of the women on
the poster was Stoya
and this she would just stare at me as I
walked by like my is better than
yours huh and I have an acting credit so
I'll you a couple months in was
dating I was in this apartment in
Brooklyn where she used to live they
broke up she moved out and I went to
change his sheets cuz it had been a
while and and I removed the fitted sheet
off of his bed and I noticed a large
puddle stain on his mattress I was like
hey Steven Q come here real quick look
just spill a gallon iced tea and your
big what the is that up and he's
like oh Stoia when she has an orgasm she
just squirts everywhere and you know oh
she does oh that's great okay hey would
you be a dear get a new mattress pad
please thank you
when I first went into his apartment I
noticed the top of his closet in his
room yeah he had all these boxes on the
top of a shelf and they had a naked lady
on them and for the longest time I was
like I don't want to know but then after
the jizz sheet thing I was like maybe I
want to know and I took a closer look
and I noticed that that naked lady was
Toya and I was like mm Steven question
quick question what the are those
and he was like oh those are Soyuz
fleshlight she forgot to take him before
she moved out I'm sorry but what's a
fleshlight if you don't know you know a
flashlight is a sex toy for a guy okay
looks like a giant plastic flashlight
you unscrew the cap and it's a
that you stick your penis it or a black
hole or mouth and all the big porn stars
have a line of flesh lights that are
molded off of their actual butt holes in
vaginas emmaus and here twelve of them
up there on the show it went like the
etiquette like you move on from one girl
to a new girl right you through old
girl's vagina in the trash it's like the
nice thing to do right it's like it's
like polite it's like manners and he's
like ah sorry throw ma'am thank you you
know
very shortly after that stoas face
appeared on the cover of the Village
Voice which is a free newspaper in New
York City it's on every street corner in
a little plastic kiosk her face is on
the cover and the headline read the
prettiest girl in New York is a porn
star it was on every corner and
like my life there was a point where my
life just became this horrible nightmare
funhouse and instead of when I looked in
the mirror instead of like seeing like a
300-pound version of myself staring back
at me it was just she was just Toya like
I would wake up in his bed in a pile of
her stale jizz I'm like all right that's
fine that whatever brush off those baths
the past and then I would go to get
dressed and I'm just staring at a shelf
of her best-selling orifices and all
right go out get a walk go for a fresh
air and uh and then I would walk outside
then there she was hanging on the front
of a porn store with a pirate
outfit on like I'm better at sex than
you whenever acting credit and then I
would literally walk ten feet to any
corner and there she was again like and
I'm prettier than you and this whole
time I was building her up in my head to
be this huge bully
it was tormenting me and and sometimes I
will respond back out loud and I'm like
you're not better than me you're not
prettier than me no you're a
whore you're just a sex worker
that's what you are yeah yeah yeah and
there was a couple times where I debated
like maybe I should just end it and
escape this and never talk to him
again and I wouldn't feel this way but
but I couldn't because as bad as that
was it didn't compare to how good it
felt to hold Stevens hand or to sit
across from him at dinner so I couldn't
and and I decided you know what I got to
change my strategy I got I got to change
what I'm doing here and I took a long
hard look at all of my insecurities and
I scooped him up and I shoved him deep
down into a dark
and I'm like I know what I got to do I
got a one-up this bitch don't ever try
to one-up a pornstar it's not gonna work
out
well the first time that I went to the
ER for a sex injury was Christmas of
2012 is our first Christmas together I'm
so excited
he got me the most amazing gifts he got
me this beautiful vintage coat and and
I'm obsessed with popcorn I eat it
everyday and he got his giant suitcase
and I opened it it was filled with 30
boxes of popcorn I was like oh my god
you know me so well and then his parents
left the room and he gave me an other
gifts I unwrapped it and it was the
biggest dildo that I have ever seen in
my entire life didn't even know they
made him that big and and you know I had
been bragging to him all this whole time
about sexual things that I didn't do but
I said I'd get him
and so out loud I was like oh yeah good
size yeah great but inside I was like
that's not gonna fit in there only exit
that in my mouth
but I was really trying to keep this
ruse up so I was like we should use it
tonight go back to his apartment at
Brooklyn and before I go in the bed I go
I go to his bathroom and I look in the
mirror and I give myself a little pep
talk I'm like Christina women have been
pushing babies out of their vaginas
since the beginning of time thank you a
boy you're born for this okay
you're gonna go in there you can take
that dildo like a grown-ass woman and
you're not gonna let him see you cry and
then I burst into the bedroom like where
is it
I can't wait so excited so much and I
purposely positioned myself so that he
was behind me and he couldn't see me go
like he's got acting credit now bitch
the whole time I was like all right this
is new but huh
maybe this is what I'm supposed to love
we had sex and we went to bed and it was
okay
but then in the middle of the night I
woke up with excruciating pain in my
lower abdomen and I woke Steven up I was
like Steven I don't know what the fuck's
happening but we need to go to the ER I
don't know what's going on we get there
and there was no gynecologist on sight
and so they had to get this very
reluctant old male doctor to stick his
fingers up me and give me an exam and
and I was crying because it it hurt was
in so much pain but it also felt kind of
rapey like I didn't want him to do it he
didn't want to do it but it kind of had
to get done and I was Holt Steven was
squeezing my hand really tight and I
looked up at him and he had a tear
rolling down his face and he was it's
who's so sad that I was in so much pain
and it was this weird connected
beautiful moment and
and the doctor is like oh you've had two
cysts on your ovaries burst and right as
I was about to say I took a pair delt on
I could handle Doc I'm sorry you caught
me obvious like oh this happens to a lot
of women and sometimes it happens out of
nowhere I'm like oh girl thank God okay
cool and then the second time I went to
the ER for a sex injury it was from but
stuff gone awry I was just pretending to
love anal and there's a lot of bleeding
involved and I wish I could say I
learned some beautiful lesson from that
story but it's just I had to eat more
fiber that was all that was was shortly
after that we moved in together and I
never lived with a boyfriend before I
was so excited and about six months into
us living together hurricane sandy hits
New York City and our apartment is
situated in a flood a zone and if you
don't know that is the flood iasts own
that is the get the out of here
zone but we stayed we're like that her
cage hurricane whatever and our
apartment is a duplex the bottom level
is in the basement of the building and
when hurricane sandy was at its peak
that basement level ended up flooding
with three feet of sewage water which I
didn't even know was possible and it
came up from the toilet and the tub and
the sink the lights were flickering on
and off I was a holy this is
Armageddon and and all of our was
getting ruined downstairs so we're
running everything upstairs as fast as
we could and I go in the closet of his
office I go to grab a box I'm like oh my
god a flashlight perfect
crabbin I couldn't really see and I
asked for the cap and I was like Oh word
there was no light bulb and I just stood
there in three feet of sewage water as
my was like floating by me getting
ruined and I just stared into the eye of
my boyfriend's ex-girlfriends butthole
and all those insecurities that I had
shoved deep deep down in that
hole came bubbling right back up and I I
ran upstairs we were butthole in my left
hand and I let him have it I
screamed at him everything that I'd ever
felt about her came out on to him I
wouldn't even let him talk and I was
like you said you would throw these away
you told me you would throw these away
and he goes I did I threw them away I
kept one because I thought it was funny
it's like how often you date somebody
with a best-selling butthole but that's
when I knew oh you're over I'm not and
and I still really it had been four
years since I've been feeling that way
and I wanted so desperately to get rid
of it and we had been debating
interviewing her on my podcast for a
long time and and he would always go you
sure and then I would say some sideways
comment about her something shitty and
the you gone man I'm not gonna do that
I'm gonna put her in that position but
that night I was like oh you're feeling
her and uh and he's like okay I'll ask
her and the next day she said okay oh
she said okay okay cool um that's that's
fine no but uh and the morning of the
interview I remember I was out the
studio showing up an hour early smoked a
pack of cigarettes outside I was like
she's not better than me she's not
better to her she's not better than
me and she rounded the corner and she
this big giant sweater on and a Fenty
Starbucks cup and she was like hey oh
this is the weirdest day ever right and
I was like I love you
and we interviewed her we interviewed
her and uh and she began to tell me all
these stories about but people in her
life that that think they know her and
they kind of treat her like a
second-class citizen because of it like
she can't get an apartment in the city
like nine times out of ten the landlord
will make her pay years worth of rent
upfront she can't get a place to stay uh
she has had bank accounts get shut down
on her by multiple banks and so of all
of her porn star friends for no reason
but you know we know the reason and uh
and she says men say these foul things
to her on the street but one of the
things that she said that really
resonated with me she goes it feels like
I'm standing on top of a pedestal inside
of a garbage can I was like but I
was so upset with myself because I
realized oh I'm a part of the
garbage can and I hated it and but ever
since that interview everything was
Steven and I it's like 20,000 pounds of
weight lifted off of my shoulders and
our relationship has been has been
amazing ever since I can be vulnerable
with him I can be honest with him I'm
sexually explorative because I want to
be but the best takeaway that I got from
interviewing her was you know in terms
of my relationship with myself and
especially with my relationship with
other women I don't want to add to the
garbage I want to be the pedestal
[Applause]